and you are this is four key I'm trashed  why four key and not sporty spark you  know he's called four key if you want to  look at these talking points there's an  explanation a fork that resembles a  spork and a stuntman who kind of looks  like Evel Knievel the similarities were  not lost on the cast do kaboom Canada's  greatest stuntman Keanu Reeves Tony Hale  and Christina Hendricks give Toy Story  for some new voices but there's plenty  of nostalgia from the original movies  help me get out of here with my foot  give him 25 years of this I still number  one is my favorite because it was number  one but boy have these guys expanded  this story woody and bizarre so iconic  their images are all over the theme  parks as Tom found out my daughter who  is in her 30s burst into tears because  she realized that some version of her  dad is going to be a Disneyland for the  rest of eternity  you don't discount that that's a  powerful thing  [Music]  [Applause]